The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
What we're going
to do today is now, as I
mentioned, shift gears.
And we're going to go from
atoms and molecules to solids.
So the outline for today is,
well, OK, so here we are.
But remember, last
time we didn't really
talk about hydrogen storage.
And some people--
well, like two people--
wanted to hear about
hydrogen storage.
So I thought what I'll do is
I will just briefly discuss
this problem--
this energy problem, which
is a very interesting problem
and really, as I'll
show at the very end,
is another one of
these huge phase space
problems where quantum
mechanical modeling is
going to be important.
OK.
And then we'll move on to
understanding what happens
when you have a crystal.
When you go from these atoms and
molecules to an ordered array
of atoms and molecules,
which is a periodic crystal,
what changes?
And there's something
really important
that changes in this
wave function that we've
been caring so much about.
And that's due to something
called Bloch's function, which
we'll talk about.
And it results in the
orbitals becoming curvy.
OK.
So that's kind of
the punch line.
That's what we're
going to build up to.
And then next week
we'll pick up from that
and talk about what that means.
OK.
Any questions at all?
Thoughts?
Hopes?
Fears?
Aspirations?
OK.
Right.
That's my hydrogen storage
introduction slide.
And what are the two problems
for hydrogen storage?
Two challenges?
Who can tell me?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Making hydrogen.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And then storing it.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Why do
we need to make hydrogen?
AUDIENCE: The Earth's
gravitational field
is [INAUDIBLE] so
it all evaporates.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Well, not all of it.
There's still some of it.
There's some of it with
which we make from.
But where is it?
It's tied up.
It's busy.
You know?
And you got to say,
hey, I need you.
Get off of that methane
molecule or get off
of this other molecule
and come over here and be
an energy carrier for me.
That takes energy to make the
hydrogen be available to use
as an energy carrier.
And then the other
problem is what?
AUDIENCE: Storing it.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Storing it.
Right.
Because it's very hard.
So I'm going to talk
about the second problem
because, again, there's sort
of a molecular solution that's
really exciting where
computation can play a role.
OK.
So I'm just going to
spend the first 15,
20 minutes here
talking about this.
I think this is--
there are high opinions
about hydrogen-- gesundheit--
storage.
And the hydrogen economy--
the hydrogen economy
is this sort of vision
that President Bush put forth.
And he really kickstarted
a large research program
in this vision where
you would be able to--
a simple chemical reaction
between hydrogen and oxygen
generates energy.
What's that called?
There's a device that does that.
That's a fuel cell.
We're not going to
talk about that part.
We're not talking about what
you do with the hydrogen
because there's all
kinds of challenges
there too, by the way.
OK.
So there's really
great research going
on in fuel cells, which are
what you put the hydrogen into
to make electricity.
There is a new
national commitment.
And there's going to be--
first car driven by
a child born today
could be powered by
hydrogen and pollution free.
Yes.
For $10 million per car.
OK.
I mean, I think a lot of
people were excited about this.
But this is a very
large investment
for government research,
which is very little money.
And in a technology
that clearly has
at least 50 years
of research that's
needed before you're
going to see a trial.
So maybe this should have said
a child's future grandchild
born today.
And that would be cool.
OK.
And yet, there are some
really great programs going on
to test the hydrogen economy.
And those are the
kinds of things
we need to do now to lay
the groundwork for all
the challenges that
have to be overcome.
Again, I'm just going
to talk about one
of them, which is storage.
But so I don't--
now, then Obama came in
and he slashed the budget.
Actually, he tried to kill it--
the hydrogen research in this
country to 0, which I thought
was interesting because
in that administration
the sense was well,
it's a great technology.
But it's a very long way off.
Let's try to work on--
reshuffle our investment a
little into other things.
Things that might
give a shorter return
in terms of technologies that
are needed in clean energy
more rapidly.
OK.
I've already shown this.
I love this history of hydrogen.
When you have a moment, just
read some Jules
Verne where he said--
I think I already
read this quote.
But he said, "I believe that one
day hydrogen and oxygen, which
together form water will
be used either alone
or together as an inexhaustible
source of heat and light."
I think that's really cool
that was in the 1800s.
And then there are
some things that
happened along the way like that
blimp thing that I showed you.
But see, now that has caused
a lot of misunderstanding
about hydrogen in that
it's, yes, it can combust.
But how dangerous is it?
So I'll show you
a slide on that.
Right.
So the problem in the storage is
that the low volumetric density
of anything that's
a gas requires
something that can densify it.
So you got to
compress it basically.
Here's your metric gasoline.
Remember, gasoline is this
beautiful high energy density
way of storing energy.
32 megajoules per liter
compared with liquid hydrogen--
if you can liquefy it, it's 8.
And gas under very
high pressure--
5,000 PSI is only 3.
So even if I squeeze
this hydrogen gas a ton,
it's still only a tenth of the
energy density of gasoline.
OK.
So that's why storing enough
hydrogen on board is hard.
And it adds a lot of
weight and volume.
And this would be how much--
this is a little less.
This is about 3,000 PSI--
200 bar-- so that would
be a gas tank of hydrogen,
which is currently how some
car manufacturers are making
hydrogen powered cars--
again, $10, $20
million per vehicle--
that store hydrogen this way.
OK.
If you could liquefy it, you
can get down to smaller tanks.
What I want to tell you about
is something that I think
is really exciting here, which
is a chemical storage approach.
OK.
Now, right.
Of course, you can imagine
that when you store things
at this high pressure or at low
temperatures and high pressures
you have very challenging
engineering and packaging
issues.
And that's one of
the biggest concerns.
And because there's also
a lot of misunderstanding
of the safety of hydrogen--
I'm not saying it's
completely safe.
But people actually are
looking at the safety
of having something
under that much pressure.
OK.
And so actually, when you
have a hydrogen powered car,
you tend to do a drop test,
which isn't really true.
They just are doing drop
tests on the containers
that they're developing.
And
They drop it so that
it's going to impact
the ground at 52 miles an hour.
And I guarantee you that
one exploding drop test,
and the market is going to have
some serious issues whatever
the cause of it is.
But this is a real
concern is the safety--
forget about whether
it's hydrogen.
But if you store anything
under that high pressure,
there are serious safety
concerns and real packaging
challenges.
OK.
Remember, it's not just
how the package operates
when you buy it,
it's how it operates
after 10 years of
corrosion and operation.
OK.
So I think chemical storage is
a really interesting way to go.
It does not involve
high pressures.
OK.
Basically, in chemical
storage, what you have is
you have essentially a sponge.
You have a material
that soaks hydrogen up.
So it literally just
absorbs hydrogen
and it changes into a hydride.
And then you pull
the hydrogen back out
and it's just a sponge.
OK.
Now the problem is that--
and there are lots
of references.
And there's lots of great
places to read about some
of this stuff.
And I've put them here--
put some of them here.
This is a really nice review.
And the problem is if you
look at the periodic table,
you see a lot of times we're
excited about materials design.
And we look at the
whole periodic table
and say, what
should we do today?
Right?
Don't you all feel that way?
That's how I feel.
Every morning-- like what
am I going to make today?
Polonium!
No.
Ciborium.
Where's ciborium?
There it is.
OK.
That's a neat material.
Ciborium carbide is
higher than diamond.
It's harder than diamond.
Right?
Now it's a problem
that see ciborium only
exists for 10 to the minus--
I don't know-- 5
seconds or something.
But still, for that
short of a time
you can make really
hard materials with it.
But see-- now-- OK--
it's a little tangent.
For hydrogen storage, you got a
big problem, which is density.
Right?
So if you're going
to use a sponge
to soak hydrogen up and then
release it when you need it
and then soak it back
up, the sponge can't
weigh 1,000 times more than
the hydrogen. That's a problem.
Right?
Because then you're just going
to add thousands of pounds
of weight to your car.
So that really limits
what you can use.
And so only the light
elements are really
going to be useful here.
And then you have a short list.
And then you say,
I don't want them
to be really that poisonous.
It might not be a good thing
in the back of your car.
Right?
And so then the list--
you can essentially
argue that the list is about
eight elements that you
might store.
And that's just not a
lot of room to play.
That's why this is challenging.
As I'm going to show
you, there actually
is more room than you think.
More and more room
as research goes on.
OK.
And so there are a lot
of materials that do fall
into-- when you combine these
eight elements together,
you can make many
different materials.
And they do fall into
a range of categories--
kinds of structures,
kinds of elements,
and so forth that can
pick up hydrogen. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm
absolutely curious.
What is metallic hydrogen
or how is it made?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well, that's--
Yeah.
Let me get to the
metal hydrides.
OK.
So these are some examples of
the densities you can get to.
OK.
Look at the density of methane.
That's a great hydrogen
storage material.
Why is it totally useless?
Somebody tell me.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] carbon.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Well, carbon isn't bad.
What?
Not so toxic.
Not a problem.
We can handle that.
AUDIENCE: Explosive.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK.
Explosive.
That could be a little
bit of an issue.
We actually like that
it's explosive-- the way
we use it today.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's hard to densify.
You sort of have
the same problem.
All right.
What if I could
make liquid methane
at really high densities?
Why would that still be a really
challenging hydrogen storage
material?
It's such a great
weight percent density.
Exactly.
You see, a sponge that's going
to-- a chemical sponge that's
going to absorb hydrogen
and give it back out when
I want it, it's got to be just
the right amount of binding.
It's got to want the hydrogen
just enough to hold onto it
but not so much that
it won't let it go.
Right?
And it turns out
that's really hard.
That window of binding
is really hard to tune.
And here it's way too
hard, way too high.
So methane-- the carbon is
holding on to those hydrogens.
And you need to go to thousands
of degrees to pull them off.
You're not going to put
a 1,000 degree Celsius
furnace in your car--
heating system-- to pull off
the hydrogen. First of all,
you just explode
your gas probably.
But also because it
takes so much energy.
Right?
So it's the kinetics.
It's getting this
hydrogen in and out
that has to be just right.
And that's where these metal
hydrides are quite interesting.
They have lower densities.
Higher though than
the targets set
by DOE, which was 6% at
least some years ago.
I forget what their
target is today.
So they're in a pretty good
range to be interesting.
And there's been a lot of work.
And I just put a few kind
of papers and examples here.
There's been a lot of work
on these different materials.
And in particular,
functionalizing materials
in different ways to
see how they pick up--
how these kinetics change--
how they pick up hydrogen.
In this case, you're still just
looking at the weight percent.
OK.
Yeah.
And same in this case.
I'll get to the kinetics
in a few minutes.
These are the sponges.
Look at this.
Sodium alanate doped with
a little bit of titanium
can give you up to 3.7% or 1.8%,
depending on how you make it.
And that's what it looks like.
There it is before you
fill it up with your fuel.
And there it is
when it's filled up.
And then it's just going
to go back and forth
and back and forth.
That's the concept, at least.
So that's basically just
restating what I said.
The metal soaks up and releases
the hydrogen like a sponge.
It becomes a part of
the chemical structure
of the material, so
it doesn't require
high pressures or cryogenic
temperatures for operation.
But it's the irreversibility
that's the problem.
How do you get to
the right kinetics?
Now, here's a chart that
I'm not going to go through.
But it's, again, just
more data for you
to look at, if you want.
And you can see that there's
a lot of work going on here.
There's a lot of really
interesting research going
on in this area for
looking at materials
that can form a hydride or not.
So they can-- like
sodium alanate
can be sodium alanate, just
sodium aluminum, the metal.
Or it can soak up the hydrogen.
And this table gives you
what weight you can expect.
And it gives you things
like what temperature
are you going to need to
go to get the hydrogen out,
because that's a really
important parameter.
And so I'm going to
finally come to-- oh.
Now, I have a few sides here
that I won't go through.
But they're just here
for you to look at,
just looking at a few cases
of different materials
that have gotten a lot of
attention in the last 10 years.
And what I do is I tell
you why they're interesting
and what their challenges are.
So we go through a few.
There's aluminum hydride.
You go from the pure
aluminum to aluminum hydride,
back and forth.
You can get up to 10% weight.
But it's almost
completely irreversible.
Now, this is the
interesting thing
that I want to tell you about.
And this is where you
start to get really
cool phase space opening up.
Again, that's what I get
really excited about.
You look at a problem in energy.
And you try to find new ways of
opening up material's design,
axes for designing materials.
And this is one of them.
It turns out that--
you see in-- let's
take magnesium.
So I showed you
aluminum, sodium.
Here's magnesium,
so another example
of one of these sponges,
these metal sponges.
And when it's sponged, no,
soaked, it looks like this.
It's got hydrogen in it.
And it's actually a pretty
decent weight percent,
7.7 weight percent.
The problem is that this
is the amount of energy it
takes to get the hydrogen out.
That's too much.
What you need for an onboard
hydrogen storage is you
need that delta
H to be somewhere
in the range of 20 to
50 kilojoules per mole.
And what is so cool is that--
what's been shown-- and this
is just a bunch of data.
But I want you to
think size going
this way and the tuning,
that delta H parameter,
on this axis.
What's been shown is that,
when it's a bulk material--
it's out here at 75--
and as you go down to smaller
sizes, that gets tuned.
And look at that.
It tunes all the way down into
the point where it's completely
reversed the stability even.
And so what you see is that,
just by changing the size,
just by nanostructuring the
material, what you're doing
is you're changing the kinetics.
You're changing the
desorbtion energy
by changing the size
of the material.
So that's an axis.
That's a tunability axis.
Now, why is this interesting--
to what?
To our class.
Why is this interesting
to quantum mechanics?
Well, because these
are all quantum
mechanical calculations.
And you can see that, even just
the different levels theory,
oh, you now know what some
of these mean, because these
are different DFT functionals.
Just look at those, three
different DFT functionals.
Well, they give
you similar trends.
But you can see that there's
still some variation.
If I go to classical potentials,
it's very, very hard to know,
when I engineer something
into a new domain like this,
if it's right.
So this is really
a problem that's
best suited for accurate
quantum mechanical methods,
because you're going to make
a classical potential that's
fit here, basically.
But all of the interesting
stuff happens as you go down
to smaller sizes.
So it goes down
into this window.
So notice that I might
want it in this range.
I might want the
desorbtion energy
to be in this range, which means
I have a very narrow window
of size that I can pick.
I better get that
right, that size right,
if I'm going to try to make
predictions of new materials.
And that's where-- again, and
then the phase space opens up
even more as you talk about--
this is nanoscaling phase space
that allows you to tune delta
H. But you can also tune it by
alloying different materials.
So now, you have this
really cool playground.
I have a bunch of different
metals, sodium, aluminum,
magnesium.
I have size.
And I have composition.
What is going to give
you the best fuel?
What's going to give
you the best kinetics?
Perfect problem for computation
and, really, a problem
that quantum mechanics
is needed for.
So that's my 20-minute
hydrogen storage ramble.
Any questions about
it before we move on?
And I'd be happy to talk more
with people about hydrogen
storage, if you'd like.
It's cool problems.
OK.
Now, I want to turn to this
goal of going from atoms
to crystals, to solids.
Now, what we're
going to do today
is just lay some of the basic
theory that we need to know.
And then next week, we're
going to start looking
at the ramifications of that.
We'll end with a band structure,
which is really exciting.
How many of you have
seen a band structure?
Yeah.
Is it fun to look
at band structures?
Have you gotten to that point?
Yeah, it's really so-so.
We'll get there.
We're going to feel really
excited about band structures,
because it's just it's
really cool stuff.
And it happens because
you go to that.
So now, we're at
this point where
we want to know about
crystals and not
just atoms and molecules.
So what happens that we
talked about so far is this.
We talked about this on Tuesday.
I have my atomic
levels, say, S and P.
And when I bring them
together to form, say,
a molecule, a dimer,
like H2, well,
then they can form
combined-- they
can form molecular orbitals.
So that's the molecule there.
And we talked about how
you can get bonding status
and antibonding states,
because you have
wiggles that are overlapping.
And so they can be in phase
and out of phase and so
forth in the wave functions.
And then you square
it to find out
the probability distributions.
But now, when I go
to a crystal, you
see you're taking this
to the next level,
to the next infinite level.
So now, you don't just
have another atom there,
you've got an atom everywhere,
all the way out to infinity.
And what ends up happening
is that, as we'll see,
is that, instead of getting
just these combined molecular
orbitals that overlap a wave
function with another wave
function, you get these bands.
You get these bands
of energy states.
And the structure of those
bands is the band structure.
And they're very-- these
don't just look like this.
They actually wiggle, which is
what's really cool about that.
Oh, there's the wiggle.
Yeah, they wiggle.
I mean, that-- I just went
from all doing all this,
drawing this a whole
bunch of times.
And now, I'm saying
they're wiggling.
So they look like this.
How is that possible?
How can an energy level wiggle?
What's it wiggling into?
That's what we're getting to.
That's called reciprocal
space or k-space.
So that's what we're
going to get to.
And I think you all know
this, but, of course,
when you talk about a
molecule, you don't usually
talk about a metal.
I mean, you talk about the
spin states of the molecule.
You can ask whether
it's magnetic or not.
But you don't usually
say it's a metal.
When you have a solid,
well, we know these terms.
It can be an insulator,
which would mean
that you have bands filled.
And we fill them, just like
in the atoms and molecules.
We get our bands.
We get our wiggles states now.
And we fill those
with electrons,
just like we did with
the atoms and molecules.
And if you fill them up, and
you're in the middle of a band
when you stop, you're a metal.
If you're here, and you
stop at the top of a band,
and there's a big jump to the
next band, it's an insulator.
If it's a little jump,
it's a semiconductor.
Anybody know what the gap of
a semiconductor is, typically?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
One point what now?
Say that again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, that
sounds about right, 1 to 3.
And what's an insulator?
AUDIENCE: Anything
higher than the--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Anything higher, maybe?
Yeah, 5, maybe.
Yeah, I love it.
And then there's the term
wide bandgap semiconductor,
which is really a term
that's used when you really
wish your material
were a semiconductor.
But it just has
a really big gap.
And most people would
call it an insulator.
We say, it's a wide
bandgap semiconductor,
so I hope it could be
useful for electronics.
Now, I think most of you
have seen crystal symmetries.
I mean, you certainly
saw it if you took 3012.
How many of you have
not seen crystals?
So this is not about
having a deep understanding
of crystal symmetries.
But there is something
important that
comes about from having periodic
potential, which is the focus.
So I just have--
I didn't want to go
into details here.
But I will just give you the
very basic elements, again,
in a couple of minutes.
When you have a
repeating pattern,
you can identify what repeats.
And that's the unit
cell in the crystal.
It's a very powerful way of
picturing an infinite material.
Because how many atoms do I
need to represent silicon?
How many of you know?
What's the structure of silicon?
Anybody know?
AUDIENCE: Cubic.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Cubic, OK.
AUDIENCE: Tetrahedral?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Tetrahedral, yes.
What's the symmetry?
Come back to that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Any others?
We'll come back to it.
But-- oh, yeah, you
have unit cells.
And they get repeated--
the cell is repeated--
on the lattice.
The lattice defines the
repeatness, the repeatiness,
repetition.
No, none of those
are good words.
But the lattice
defines how it repeats.
Is it going to repeat like
this, in a rectangular way?
Is it going to repeat
in a square way?
And you fill all of space.
If you fill all of
space, then it's
a particular kind of lattice.
Now, because a
crystal is periodic,
the whole point here is we don't
have to model all the atoms.
Because if we did,
we'd need to model 10
to the 23rd, which
would be a bummer.
And so what's cool is
that, since it's periodic,
we can just model the ones
that periodicalize, or repeat.
And these are the
crystal symmetries
that fill all of space.
So this is all, for those
of you who had 3012,
I know this is just review.
You have, basically,
seven symmetry classes,
crystal classes, sorry.
Some of you talked about cubic.
And then you have
different types
of unit cells, which, basically,
is just whether you have,
in the repeat cell,
atoms in every corner,
in every corner in the center,
in the faces, all faces,
some faces.
Those are four options.
And when you bring
it all together,
you have 14 of these
kinds of lattices,
which are the ones that
can fill all of space.
Those are Bravais lattices.
This is all mostly
review, right?
And it's not critical.
But, yeah, is this feeling--
are you feeling good about this?
Yeah.
You like it.
So here's two different
kinds of crystals.
And then you have the
crystal lattice, which
is determined by these dots.
And then you have the basis,
which can be anything.
You can put a basis on the dot.
Now, this is how we're going to
talk to our code, by the way.
When we model a
solid, this is what
we're going to tell it,
because it needs to know.
It's going to need to know.
When you run your SIESTA
code-- and we'll do that--
we'll run some SIESTA
calculations next week--
it's going to want to know
what your lattices, well,
what symmetry lattice you have.
Is it FCC?
Is it simple cubic?
And then it's going to want
to know the lattice spacing.
And then it's going to want to
know everything in your basis.
Is it one atom in your basis?
Is it like FCC, with
two atoms in your basis,
which sounds a lot
like silicon to me?
Or is it something
like, with Mickey Mouse,
which cannot be entered
into a computer?
So that's how you're
going to input structures.
Now, here's where it
gets really interesting.
And this is where--
this is really the
key of today's lecture
is the next five,
six lines, next bit.
There is something called an
inverse lattice, which is also
called reciprocal space.
And I think because--
I think you did learn all
this, if you had 3012, yes?
So you all feel--
do you feel your oneness
with reciprocal space?
Yeah, I'm seeing
some strong nods
and some not-so-strong nods.
So this is a really
important concept
that, essentially, gives this.
It gives us the wiggles.
This reciprocal
space is the language
we need to describe the wiggles.
So just to review
for most of you,
with each real space lattice,
like the square that I
showed you, you can make
a reciprocal lattice.
And it's the set
of vectors that are
commensurate with the
real space lattice.
And you can define them
very, very ingeniously.
If the real space lattice
is vectors a, b, and c--
oh, like here,
it's a 2D lattice.
So this would be like a.
That would be vector a.
And maybe, this
would be vector b.
This would be vector b.
Which one?
Any thoughts?
We're just brushing up here.
But you call them a
star, b star, and c star.
And the way they're defined
is in a very important way.
First of all, a star--
that's the reciprocal
vector-- times a is 1.
So there's a normalization.
And secondly, there's something
a little more mathematically
rigorous, which is that it's the
cross product of the other two.
So a star is the cross
product of b and c.
b star is the cross
product of c and a.
So you can write down--
basically, when you
have your real space
lattice and-- hello there.
[DOOR CLOSES]
Why do I have those little n's
there in front of those vectors
to define my real space lattice?
This is what we use
to talk about lattice?
Why are those n's there?
AUDIENCE: Signify
the twilight zone.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
The twilight zone?
Very good guess.
What does n usually mean
when I put it in an equation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: A what number?
AUDIENCE: Integer.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Some integer, yeah.
Why?
I don't know.
We just like n for integer.
It just happened.
So why would those be integers?
a1, a2, a3 are the
vectors of the lattice.
And now, I have integers there.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
because this is my lattice.
This is my lattice.
It goes off to infinity.
so it's n is 1 to get here,
2 get there, 3 to get there.
That's why it's n.
It's an integer times
the lattice factor.
And it gets me to any
other lattice point,
depending on what my n's are.
Now, the same-- in
reciprocal space,
you construct another
lattice, which
is given by these mathematical
expressions, as I said,
just cross products
of the first lattice.
And you get a
reciprocal lattice,
which we like to call G.
We say that those have
their own lattice vectors and
their own integers in front
that take you anywhere you
want in the reciprocal lattice.
Now, a couple of
important things, one
is, if I take e
to the iG.R, where
R is a lattice
vector in real space,
and G is a lattice vector in
reciprocal space, I get 1.
That's important.
You'll see in a minute why.
But also, if I happen
to write a function that
looks like something like this,
where I have it as an exponent,
e to the i some
reciprocal lattice vector
times R, where R can now
be anywhere in real space--
R is just a vector--
it's not a lattice vector--
then that function
will automatically
be periodic in the real space.
Isn't that cool?
That function will
automatically be periodic.
That sounds like
something we might want.
Now, here's a simple picture.
This is a real
space BCC lattice.
And when I construct the
inverse lattice using
the mathematical rules
I just showed you,
I get this, which is cool.
BCC turns into FCC.
When you do the
inverse lattice, you
get a new lattice,
which happens to be FCC.
So it's just a new space,
but it's reciprocal space.
Now, why is this so important?
We're getting there.
Within this reciprocal
space, you can define a zone.
And you can define
it very simply.
You just draw-- you just
go out to your-- you
just go out to the
next point here.
And you draw your
bisection lines.
So you go out to these points.
And you draw lines.
In this case, it's a 2D lattice.
So the area that's
carved out is a zone.
And that, when you do it with
just to the first neighbors,
when you do it like that,
and you draw the lines,
you get the Brillouin zone.
Did you guys talk about
Brillouin zone in the fall?
It's just this very
first zone, first--
I don't want to get
too technical here.
But it's the zone we care
about in the calculations.
This part of the
reciprocal space
is all we need,
this Brillouin zone.
He was a cool guy.
And you can go out--
you can keep doing this
and go to the next
nearest neighbors
and drop bisecting lines
and create the next volume.
And here are just
a few examples.
The first Brillouin
zone is what we're
going to be interested in.
This is what it looks like
for BCC and FCC lattices.
And then you can go out to
further and further points.
And you get some really
interesting volumes here.
Again, I'm not going to
go too much into this.
But we do care about
this Brillouin zone.
And I'll tell you why when
we get to the band structure.
No, I'll tell you why right now.
You see-- and then
I'll come back to it,
because it might not make
total sense right now--
you see, the Brillouin
zone is an area of--
it's a volume, in 3D, of
space, of reciprocal space, not
real space, reciprocal space.
And what ends up
happening-- so again,
I'm jumping to the
punchline here--
but I want to tell to
you while you're thinking
about this Brillouin zone--
is that, you see, when you
move around in reciprocal space
within this first Brillouin
zone, what ends up happening
is that the wave function
can change, depending
on where it is in that zone.
Now, that's a result of
having a periodic potential
and this thing called
Bloch's Theorem, which
we're going to talk about next.
But that is what leads the
variation in the energies
is what leads to the curviness.
This curviness, if you
want to think about it,
is a tour through
the Brillouin zone.
I take a tour through
this special zone
in reciprocal space.
And I find that the
wave function varies.
So I may take a tour by going
from the middle of the zone
out to one of these edges.
Maybe I'll go up to the middle
of the plane here of the phase
and back to the edge.
And you cruise around
this Brillouin zone.
And that's what
gives you wiggles.
That's how you get the wiggles.
I mean, the crystal is
what gives you the wiggles.
The way you calculate
them is by cruising around
in reciprocal space in the code.
By the way, in this
part of the class,
I'm very purposefully not
going into technical details
of the codes.
However, if anyone
is interested,
I would be very happy
to work with you
or share with you more details
about how the codes are doing
these calculations, what's the
math under the hood, what kind
of loops are happening.
And you're certainly
welcome to download codes.
There are free ones that--
for solids, you can download,
for free, SIESTA, which
is what's running on the hub.
You can download PWSCF.
You can download ABINIT.
These are just a few
that come to mind.
They're free.
You can download them.
Most of them, I think you
can run on your laptop.
And if you're
interested in going more
under the hood in the codes, I'd
be very happy to talk to you.
But that's not the focus
of this part of the class,
as I've said.
For molecules-- as I've said,
there are many codes here--
this is just a very
short list-- but there's
GAMES and NWCHEM, which are
a few that come to mind,
both free.
And then there are
bunch that you pay for.
If you want to spend
some money, if you
got 5, 10 grand to spare,
first, come see me and--
[LAUGHTER]
--I'm kidding.
But you can buy VASP.
Or you could buy a
code called Gaussian,
which are both-- we heavily
use VASP in my group.
These are very good
codes, actually.
But they cost money.
They have some-- these
different codes are all
doing the same thing.
They're all doing Schrodinger.
And they're all using their
approximations we talked about.
And they have different
advantages and disadvantages,
which, again, I'd be happy
to talk with people about,
if they'd like to
dig a little deeper.
Now, all of this stuff
about the Brillouin zone,
which comes from the
symmetries of the crystal,
comes into play because we
have periodic potentials.
That's it.
That's the point.
So I now went from a potential
that looks like this.
Well, let me try to--
if there's an atom here,
there's a potential well
that an electron might feel as
it gets attracted to the atom.
And I went from putting, maybe,
two atoms together to now
having an array of them
that go out to infinity.
Now, that has repercussions.
And so the potential,
now, can be written.
So you could try to
write the whole thing out
as a function of all of space.
Or you can just say,
hey, for every plus R,
I get back to V, because
that's basically what it is.
It's a periodic
potential in the lattice.
So the potential now, every
R, which is a lattice vector,
is the same.
Now, it turns out this is
actually really hard to solve.
And in textbooks, in
quantum textbooks,
like if you take a solid state
physics class, what you'll see
is that they'll show
this picture, especially
from a long time ago--
there's some really
good solid state physics
texts from the '70s.
And you look at some
of those older ones,
they'll show those pictures,
say, it's too hard to solve.
And I love that, because
it's not anymore,
because we can use
computers to do it,
which is what we're going
to do in this class.
But back then, and
even longer before,
it was too hard to solve.
And so people would basically
model a crystal going back
exactly to the problem of
an atom and the potentials
being so hard to
solve analytically
unless they're simple.
They simplified this.
And if you make
it a periodically
repeating square
well like that, you
could solve it analytically.
And for those of you
who are interested,
this is called the
Kronig-Penney model.
And you can look up--
I think that's how
you spell Penney.
You could look up the solution
to that online, if you want.
It won't happen-- we're not
going to do it in the class.
But beyond simple
things like this,
which is not a very realistic
crystal, although you
do get some key physical meaning
out of this, beyond that,
you need a computer, which
I think is pretty cool.
So now, we get to
Bloch's Theorem,
which is what gets us to
this dependence, this wiggle,
this wiggle.
So we're setting it up.
We have reciprocal space.
We defined this first
zone in reciprocal space.
We said that, if you go through
the zone, things change.
Bloch's Theorem is the reason.
It's the reason
why things change
as you tour through this zone.
There are different ways to
talk about Bloch's Theorem.
Here's a fairly simple
way to look at it.
So if you write the reciprocal
lattice vector like this,
2 pi-- and the
2's are just there
to make math a
little easier, so you
can write it however you want.
This is that integer.
There's the reciprocal
lattice vector.
If you write it like that, then,
if you take this exponential--
[SNEEZE]
--gesundheit-- which I've
already alluded to before,
and you do that,
actually, explicitly out.
So R is a vector in real space.
R is a vector in real space.
Now, if I dot R with G, which
is a reciprocal lattice vector,
then I get the reciprocal
lattice vector dot that.
And that's just alpha, beta,
gamma, or just the coefficients
of the real space
lattice vector,
because R will be
somewhere in real space.
And so I can represent it, in
terms of the real space lattice
vectors time some coefficients.
And what you can see when you
do this, it's very simple math.
What you can see is
that, as you vary where
you are in real space,
then, well, these things
are going to change.
Alpha, beta, and gamma would
change between, say, 0 and 1.
And the function e to
the iG.r changes as well.
But you can see from
this little derivation
that, since these are integers,
this function is always going
to vary with the periodicity.
So this is what I said.
Here's the math behind it.
I said this before.
So you now have a
function, e to the iG.R
And that's the reason why.
If you just spend a few
minutes staring at it,
you'll see why this is true.
You have a way of making
a function automatically
periodic.
Now, why do I care?
Well, because if I
have this periodicity,
if I have this ordering--
here, it's drawn is
an approximation.
Here, it's drawn as
maybe more realistic,
what my potentials look like.
Then the values of some
function, like the density,
should be what at
each lattice site?
Well, I have it there in blue.
AUDIENCE: They'd be
identical [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Now, that seems obvious.
I mean, I've got,
basically, an array
that goes on forever that's
the same every lattice vector.
It's just the same thing.
This is a pure, perfect crystal.
There are no defects.
It's completely unrealistic,
because, as you all know,
there are defects in reality.
But we can put those into
the simulation as well.
But for this derivation,
there's no defects.
So you have infinite crystal.
And what that means is that,
everywhere, the properties
should be the same.
If I sit on this atom or this
atom or in between these two
and then in between
those two, the properties
should be the same, if I
go by a lattice vector.
Here's the kicker, though.
The wave function
is not the same.
And that's really the key.
The wave function
is not the same.
It's almost the
same, but it's not.
It's periodic.
The wave function
is periodic but only
when it's multiplied
by a phase factor.
And that is Bloch's Theorem.
And there are three
or four different ways
that it can be derived.
I will post them onto
the Stellar website.
They're not something you need
to know for quiz or homework.
But that is Bloch's Theorem.
It's that the wave function
in a infinitely repeating
periodic crystal is going
to equal some function that
is periodic, some
function that's
periodic that has the
periodicity of the lattice,
some function, u,
times the phase.
And that, this is
that function u.
You see, it's periodic.
It equals it, if you go plus
big R, plus one lattice vector.
So if you move over by a whole--
when I see lattice
vector, by the way,
let's bring it to reality.
I just mean if
silicon were cubic,
I'd just be going from one
silicon atom to another.
That's a lattice vector.
And simple cubic, I'm thinking.
And so you have a
function that also
is the same in that
lattice distance,
as you go from, say, one atom
to another in the simplest case.
But the wave function
is that times the phase.
And that's really
important, because that
brings in a new variable.
In fact, this is a
new quantum number.
That brings in a
This is a quantum number, k,
that lives in inverse space.
So Bloch's Theorem says that,
if I go from one point in space
to another point that's
translated by just a lattice
factor, then I equal my original
wave function time this phase.
And you can show--
I mean, this is
actually trivial,
because this is
a complex number.
So when you square
it, you can show
that the squares are the same,
which is really important.
The charge density in
the lattice is periodic.
Does everybody see that?
The charge density in a
crystal should be periodic.
Between any two
silicon atoms, the bond
is the same for as long as
you can see, 10 to 23rd bonds.
It's a whole lot of sameness.
And you can see that the
equations show that it is.
But the wave function
can vary by this phase.
You can also show that if
psi k, this thing that I'm
going to talk about more, is
a solution to the Schrodinger
equation, then psi k
plus any reciprocal--
this is a reciprocal number.
Remember, this is a number.
k is a vector in
reciprocal space.
That's the Bloch's Theorem.
That's a reciprocal vector
that lives in reciprocal space
dotted with the lattice vector.
And if I add the reciprocal
lattice vector to it,
then that also
must be a solution.
So that's also another
consequence of Bloch's Theorem.
So here's the--
I know some of you
might not quite
be feeling your
oneness with this.
That's fine.
We'll talk about this a
little bit more next week.
I don't need you to go into
great fundamental depth
in Bloch's Theorem
and how it's derived.
And I'll show you,
you can basically--
because proper derivations
require some more knowledge
of quantum mechanics.
And I'm trying to avoid that.
But basically, one of the
easiest ways to look at it
mathematically is that
the translation vector
associated with the lattice
commutes with the Hamiltonian.
Anybody know what that means?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that like
how we take ab equals ba?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, kind of.
Yeah, so you can switch the
order of the operations.
But that's, again, not--
we don't need to know that.
What we need to know is this.
This is what we need to know.
This is the punchline of it all.
So we've gone through
some derivation.
We won't do more
much more derivation.
But this is the punch line.
This is what you got
to take out of this,
so please do take this away.
When we had hydrogen atoms,
when we solved the Schrodinger
equation for a
hydrogen atom, we saw
that the way we did it was we
imposed spherical symmetry.
So we had a symmetry.
We did have a symmetry.
It wasn't a crystal
symmetry, which I showed you,
14 Bravais lattices.
But it was a
symmetry, spherical.
And when I imposed that, we saw
that there are-- these quantum
numbers came out, remember?
We did that.
And that was so
cool, because it just
solved so many of the
issues of the time,
just the fact that
electrons were quantized
was so important.
All right.
Now, we have a new
kind of symmetry.
We have something called
translational symmetry.
We're still solving the
Schrodinger equation,
but now it's a periodic solid.
And when this kind of
symmetry is in the game,
we have a different
kind of quantum number.
That's what matters most here.
We have a different
kind of quantum number.
We have a quantum number that
is a reciprocal lattice vector.
It's a vector in
reciprocal space.
That's the key.
And because we
have-- you see, just
like-- so these l's and
m's had their rules.
This could be plus or minus
that and so forth and so on.
And so you could--
they lived within I don't know.
They lived within
in the counting
of the principal quantum number.
Now, we have a
different situation.
We have a quantum
number that can vary.
It doesn't have to just be 0, 1.
Or it's not necessarily tied to
the principle quantum number.
But it can vary.
And its domain of varying
is that Brillouin zone.
That's it.
So that's where it can play.
These guys have
variations dictated
by the principal quantum number.
This has variations dictated
by the Brillouin zone.
That's really the key
here, the Brillouin zone,
which comes about
from reciprocal space.
Is everybody with me?
Well, here's just a drawing.
I don't even know where--
I should really have
a reference here.
This is one of my
Google image searches.
And there are many.
And you can look
at drawings online.
But if you have a very
simple wave function--
that's the real and
imaginary parts--
and you have some periodically
repeating function--
so that's my psi, and that's
my periodic function--
then you can get a
sense of this variation
that I'm talking about.
This is a very simple
one-dimensional example.
So I have a one-dimensional
wave function.
And I have a periodically
repeating function.
And remember, what
Bloch's Theorem says
is that that is
now how I'm going
to write a solution to
the Schrodinger equation.
It's going to be a combination
of a plane wave like that,
where k is in the
reciprocal space,
and some periodically
repeating function.
And just to illustrate that you
can get variation now, check
out what happens when I change
k from, say, something not
equal to 0 to something
like pi over a,
you can see that these
functions change dramatically.
The wave function of
the crystal changes.
Everybody see that?
So that's really important.
And the reason that's
important and the reason
this is all going to come
home for us as we move on
to seeing why this all matters
is that that means you have
energies that also depend on k.
The energies also depend on this
variation in reciprocal space.
All right.
So now, if I'm in
reciprocal space,
and I move from the
origin out to the edge
of the Brillouin zone, not
only am I changing my function,
I'm changing this.
I'm changing-- the position
of this level can vary now.
It now can vary.
It can move up or down.
And that's the key
result, the one that's
going to matter most to us.
Is everybody-- any questions?
This is-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, is the k
right here that
we're dealing with,
is that the same as
the crystal momentum?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Very good, yes,
the crystal momentum would
be that times h bar, yes,
which is like momentum,
kind of, but not really.
But it is, sort of.
AUDIENCE: So it--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Quasi
is a good word, momentum.
AUDIENCE: So it it an
inverse lattice vector or--
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Ah,
well, that is exactly it,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you can get a feel for--
as you vary k, so then things
happen, like the momentum
can change.
And that means the
velocity can change.
And if the velocity can change--
well, actually, the
mass can change as well.
And if those things can change--
of course, it's not
really changing.
The mass of the electron
isn't really changing.
But the effective mass, the mass
that it feels in the crystal,
is changing.
And, boy, is that important.
And we'll talk about that,
because, from the way that--
here's my levels in
an atom or molecule.
And now, remember, I
said that they do this.
From the way they do this, how
heavy an electron feels itself
to be in the crystal varies.
It has an effective mass that's
dependent on the wiggles here.
And because of that,
that's directly related
to how fast an electron can
cruise through the crystal.
It's directly related
to the mobility.
So the transport
properties are deeply
dependent on this wiggling.
So Bloch's Theorem
is a formal theorem
that tells you that you have
to write wave functions in such
a way that you have a dependence
on the inverse lattice.
And then how that dependence
enters into a system
or a material is very complex.
And it depends on solving
the Schrodinger equation
for the material.
But you see, you can think
about it like this, if you want.
Here's my inverse space.
And I'm going to change where
I am in reciprocal space.
Remember, again, I only
have reciprocal space
because I have a crystal.
I have a lattice.
So I have an inverse space.
And if I change where
I am in inverse space,
these would be my
new energy levels.
You get a new set
of energy levels,
those e's that I just showed
you, for every point in space,
in k-space, every
point in k-space.
So now, this is just blown up.
It used to be the good
old days, last Thursday.
We just had these levels.
We just got through talking
about how you get these from--
you can build up two
atoms, three atoms.
And you get these levels.
And they didn't go anywhere.
And now, they've blown up,
because anywhere you go
in this reciprocal
space, they can change.
They can change.
So now, you need to
compute those same levels
in the computer for
different points in k-space.
And that's what a computer does
when it solves for a solid.
That's what it does.
That's basically the
difference, is you now
have an extra degree of
freedom that you didn't have
in your atoms and molecules
or an extra quantum number
that you need to explore, k.
So what are my levels at 0?
Well, there are these.
I don't know.
Well, they're not here.
What are my levels here?
They look like this.
Here, they look at this.
And that's how the
computer does it.
It computes the same thing.
It computes the energy
levels, fills them up.
But at each point in k-space,
they can be different.
And this is exactly
that difference.
You change where
you are in k-space.
And look at that.
This level starts going down.
This level goes up.
I don't know what's
going on here.
Maybe that's this one.
That one's going up.
All kinds of things can
happen as you cruise around
phase space, in k-space.
Those energy levels will change.
And that is what leads
to a band structure.
That's what a band structure is.
It's just a continuous
change of energy levels
as a function of k-space.
And each of these bands is
still just an energy level.
So how many
electrons go into it?
Still just an energy
level, it's just
a weird one that wiggles
depending on where you
are in the reciprocal lattice.
But how many electrons
do I put into this band
as I fill them up?
Two, I still just put
two electrons in here.
And then I put two
electrons in here.
electrons here.
Oh, but look at that.
It was actually two bands.
That's tricky.
So you get these really
interesting behaviors,
where bands can merge
and become degenerate.
Ah, but that's not really
that different, is it,
then the idea that
you could have
states like this, where I had--
this is just the atom, 1S 2S,
2P.
I had three energy bands
that had the same energy.
That's called degeneracy.
Here it is in the hydrogen atom.
There it is in a
very complex crystal.
Well, it's actually
a simple crystal.
So you have
degeneracies, where--
these would be like two levels
that are the same energy.
But now, I'm cruising
around in k-space.
And I get to a part of
k-space where they no longer
are the same.
They actually split.
This one goes down.
And these two go up, let's say.
And so their degeneracy splits.
And you see that all the
time in band structures.
But there are a certain
number of total levels here.
And you fill them
up, just like we
did for an atom or a molecule.
Now, somebody tell me what--
so that's a band structure.
We'll talk about the band
structure in all of its glory
next week.
But we're not done.
Somebody tell me-- by the way,
this is a beautiful thing.
Are we feeling that?
I mean, is it a little
emotional moment for you
guys, a little bit?
Yeah?
I felt that.
There's so much in
the band structure.
There is so much
material science, so much
physics and chemistry,
in this band structure,
so much to learn about a
material, just from this.
So we still have
occupied and unoccupied.
That wasn't supposed to do that.
Oh, why is it doing that?
OK, there we go.
So you still-- that's what
I was saying-- you still
will fill them up.
And then you'll have--
what is that?
AUDIENCE: Bandgap.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
That's the bandgap.
But what's interesting
about this bandgap?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's indirect.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's indirect.
And now, that's what
indirect means, you see.
Can I get an indirect--
remember, we had the molecules.
We had the molecules.
This is a molecule.
Those are my energy
levels of a molecule.
And this was the gap.
Can I have an indirect
bandgap in a molecule?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: If it's a
molecule of silicon.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Well, even
if it's a molecule silicon,
can I have an indirect bandgap?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: It's not periodic.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It's not periodic.
Therefore?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
there is nothing to vary.
K-space does
nothing for me here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
what an indirect bandgap is?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And I'm going to
talk about a lot.
Yeah, sorry, I jumped
a little ahead.
I get a little excited.
Indirect bandgap is
such a cool thing.
And it's such a pain
point in silicon.
You see, if I want--
what you're going
to do in homework 2,
and what we talked about
last Thursday, is that,
if I shine light onto
this material-- remember,
these are all occupied--
what I can do is kick an
electron up in energy.
That's a photoexcitation.
And that's what allows
me to store energy
from the sun in the
molecules you're
going to work on in
your next problem set.
But you see, that's
just a direct bandgap.
Why is it direct?
Well, because it's
just the bandgap.
In a molecule, there's
no direct or indirect.
But this is direct,
because you just
have the energy from the sun.
And that's the energy
that it needs to go up.
Now, when you have k-space,
things are different.
Because now, these things,
these energies, they wiggle.
And here's the kicker.
You see, what's the gap
now of this material?
Well, here, they wiggle.
Don't look at that for a second.
Just look at this.
I now don't have a molecule.
I have a periodically
repeating solid.
And therefore, I get these
wiggles of each energy band.
And now, I shine light on it.
Where does this electron go?
Is this the gap of the material?
That's the key.
Is that the gap?
Well, it's the gap at
this point in k-space.
But here's the real
important part.
There is a lower energy
gap in this material.
If I'm able to go from
this point k-space
to this point in k-space,
then the gap is only this big.
This would be
called a direct gap.
And this would be
called an indirect gap.
And that is why silicon
solar cells are expensive.
We will talk about
that next week.
But that's why silicon
solar cells are expensive.
You see, when you have to go
to a different part of k-space
to create your excitation,
well, you need help.
You can't do it with just light.
You need some assistance.
You've got to call it in.
And that means it's
a lot harder to do
and, therefore, a very
inefficient process.
And as we talked
about last week,
and as you'll do
in your homework,
you want to absorb as much
of that sunlight from the sun
as you can.
So if your gap--
our next application-- not
Tuesday but probably next
Thursday, we might
start to talk about it--
will be solar cells.
And we'll talk about
solar cells then.
But you don't want your bandgap
to be too high, because if it's
really high,
remember, you're not
going to absorb much of the sun.
Now, it also can't
be 0 or close to 0
for a similar reason of the
solar fuels but different.
But it's related.
And we'll get to that later.
But the point is that this gap
is very high for a solar cell.
This is a big gap.
You want it to have a small gap.
It does have a small gap.
Silicon does have a small
gap from here to here, 1.1,
beautiful EV.
But it needs to call it in.
It needs help.
It can't just get that
from the light alone.
And therefore, that's a very low
efficiency process and a very
low probability process.
So yes, it can absorb
light, if it has
help at those lower energies.
But it's very infrequent.
It's very improbable.
And that indirect bandgap is
the reason why silicon is not
a good optical
absorber, does not
absorb light efficiently in
the parts of the spectrum
that you'd like it to.
It can absorb light, if
you make it thick enough
in that part of the spectrum.
But that's not what
you want to do.
But you got to do it.
So that's the indirect bandgap.
Now, does everybody
see-- but, see,
it has a direct gap at gamma.
Does everybody see this?
It's a really cool important--
[PHONE RINGING]
--result. Tell them
you'll call them back
unless it's about the band
structure of silicon, whoever's
phone that was.
Now, somebody tell
me what would happen
if I spaced my molecules--
this is a silicon solid.
Now, what would happen--
oh, let me, in the last
few minutes of class--
uh-oh, what's it doing?
Yeah, that doesn't
look good, does it?
Somebody tell me
what would happen
if I spaced my
atoms in the crystal
further and further apart.
What's going to happen
to that band structure
if I make them go further
and further apart?
AUDIENCE: You'll smooth it out.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What is that?
AUDIENCE: You'll smooth
it out [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
You'll smooth it out.
What will happen eventually?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, exactly.
So I can plot the band
structure of an atom.
And what would I get?
My variation in
case based will be?
What would the band
structure-- what
would the variation in
k-space for an atom be,
just an isolated atom?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Zero variation,
exactly, everything's flat.
You're the same
everywhere in k-space.
You're just back to the picture
that we've been working in.
So let's just see.
Now, you'll use this to
do molecule calculations
for your next homework.
But we'll do some calculations.
I just want to show
one last point.
And we'll do some
calculations also next week.
Oh, it's loading.
The nanoHUB toolkit is loading.
How do I-- do you think--
tell me, while this is loading--
if it ever finishes--
tell me what you think is going
to be an additional convergence
parameter for solids.
Think about this picture.
It looks like that
may never load.
Think about this picture here
and tell me what you think
is going to be an
important convergence
parameter for solids.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
it's exactly right.
I mean, because
now, how am I going
to know if the
variation is correct?
This variation I'm
telling you is extremely
important for crystals.
This is what goes
to a band structure.
This is what gives you
your band structure.
Is it right?
Well, did you do enough
of these energy level
calculations at enough
points in k-space?
The code will now have
that as an input, you see.
Ah-ha, there it is, beautiful.
I think this is a bust here.
Ah, oh, this is exciting.
This reminds me of the
days of dial-up modem.
I just read about them.
I don't know about
them, of course.
So here you go.
This is SIESTA.
It's not letting me scroll
down again, beautiful--
run JML viewer, solid.
It's not responding.
That's also interesting.
Oh, there's the scrollbar.
Can I run it?
It's really not-- yeah,
I can't even click this.
Ah-ha, oh, yeah--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Right.
That's the first time
that's ever happened.
AUDIENCE: I got that last night.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Well, so anyway,
that would have been
a band structure of silicon.
But what you can see
here, look at this.
Oh, but look under here.
You see, don't pay
attention to that.
Look at this, k-point density.
That is a new convergence
parameter for solids.
Can I get a wiggly band
structure for silicon
with just one k-point
in my simulation?
You can, actually.
And I'll tell you why.
Will it be right?
No.
And I'm going to
pick up on that point
to make sure we understand
this convergence parameter
when we start next week.